and this morning the united kingdom has
a king for the first time in 70 years
and its people are in mourning for the
only monarch most of them have ever
known
queen elizabeth ii was 96 years old when
she died yesterday at balmoral castle
that's her summer home in scotland
buckingham palace announced the news at
6 30 p.m local time the statement said
she died peacefully but gave no other
details here's a look at the gates
outside balmoral where mourners are
leaving flowers and notes in honor of
the queen
as you would expect this is front page
news all over the world
newspapers are remembering the queen in
her record long reign as britain begins
an official period of mourning that will
last through her funeral hard to believe
but the last time we saw the queen was
in these photos taken just on tuesday as
she appointed another bit of ceremony
liz trust to become britain's new prime
minister the 15th prime minister the
queen met in this way after she died
trust spoke to reporters outside 10
downing street
queen elizabeth ii
was the rock on which modern britain was
built
today the crown passes
as it has done for more than a thousand
years
to our new monarch our new head of state
his majesty king charles iii
and the new king is expected to meet
with the prime minister later today one
of the first official acts he will take
as britain's monarch charles is also
expected to make a speech on national
television 6 pm
local time this afternoon here in the
u.s and we have a team of correspondents
who've been following this news since
yesterday they're in london and
elsewhere we're going to have full
coverage of this
truly era defining story over the next
two hours but we're going to go first to
holly williams back outside buckingham
palace where thousands of people
gathered yesterday to mourn the nation's
loss gathered in the hours after the
news broke and gathered still this
morning in a light rain holly good
morning
good morning well this moment was of
course inevitable but there's still a
sense of shock here because it's so hard
to imagine this country without her
and for many british people the queen
embodied what they believe is best about
themselves yes she was reserved a woman
of few words but she was also reliable
steadfast and had a religious commitment
to her nation
our last images of the queen
still with a mischievous smile still
doing her duty
meeting britain's new prime minister
just two days before her passing this is
bbc news from london
buckingham palace has announced the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth ii
that was how her people heard they'd
lost a much-loved monarch
outside buckingham palace's golden gates
her death was announced in traditional
style but even before that with the
worrying news of her poor health crowds
were gathering
as a double rainbow appeared overhead
[Applause]
god saved the queen they sang this
country's national anthem
except now it will become god save the
king
truly the end of an age spelled out by
the british prime minister
we usher in a new era in the magnificent
history of our great country
exactly as her majesty would have wished
by saying the words
god save the king
the first news that she was seriously
ill came at around noon yesterday the
palace saying her doctors were concerned
for her majesty's health
in the reserved language of the royal
family that was enough
the country held its breath
close family members including charles
princess william and harry raced to the
queen's summer home balmoral castle in
scotland
by the early evening we were told she
was gone how are you
well as you can see i can't move the
queen has looked frail for months
often using a walking stick and there
was a wave of public sympathy as she
buried her husband prince philip last
year
but when she celebrated her platinum
jubilee this past june marking 70 years
on the throne she didn't just greet her
people from the balcony of buckingham
palace
she stole the show
tea
oh yes please
appearing in this witty sketch with
paddington bear
happy jubilee
[Music]
that's very kind
she is an impossible act to follow
a woman
a queen
and the iconic face of her country
she ascended the throne of fresh-faced
25 year old mother she left it a great
grandmother and she leaves behind a
grateful nation
and that's the word here this morning
gratitude
eureka
what a legacy and what a piece holly
williams force at buckingham palace
thank you